you're the head writer for the original
Triumph remote at the Westminster yes
was that the first time we did well
first remote was with it at the dog show
the first the first dog show yes and you
were the head writer John but uh well
actually when I had the idea for Triumph
I called you up after taking a shower it
was like 1997 and like can we do another
dog show I have one more yeah one last
comedy one last idea for a dog Talent
insult comic and that's how that started
but then it was a couple of years later
Sweeney was the one who suggested the
Triumph through a remote oh a dog show
it was great I just watched it this
morning it all came from Sweeney I'd
never thought of doing remotes with
Triumph I just watched the Westminster
dog show on this morning just to refresh
my memory and it's the one which one the
first the first one it was the very
first one the second one was insane too
well the second one was under danger of
like being arrested right because they
were they were so on
Guardians
second one was where I was really like I
need help with I and I gathered the
writers and writers really wrote jokes
for that one yeah first one just went in
there and like we're just gonna
around and it worked because it was so
fresh and new
and um and there were some judges and
there's people who are good sports too
and played along yeah yeah some people
were great Sports and loved just having
their dog on camera and then there were
other people who weren't especially uh
shocking you know yeah dog groomer right
yeah yeah I think the second one was
where you got into it with dog groomers
they really got bent out of shape yes I
think so and the second one was where
Triumph the premise was the Triumph goes
back in Disguise because he was thrown
out I really once thrown out of the
first one yeah I was out of the first
one like really early and and then I had
to like improvise just like in the lobby
off of like photographs of dogs all
right which were those but those were
great jokes those were really funny that
was like improv that first one and then
but and we had already had our ending
because that's how I got thrown out was
humping individual not me but Triumph
humping individuals
when people are gonna extrapolate so uh
but yes that was but what I want to say
just if anybody ever wants to listen to
first time I was on this show I
explained very in very detailed manner
how Jordan schlansky made that mode
possible great the whole his whole Nam
to plume or whatever you call it is just
that he does nothing on the show but if
Jordan hadn't been
so devious and uh Relentless in getting
us into Westminster with fake IDs
he's the reason that that remote ever
got off the ground and then he's been
co-hosted
his reward was be basically becoming
Triumph in the yeah right
he's Conan's puppet now but since we
have Robert here I get to I wanted to my
favorite Triumph well there's so many
Triumph remotes that were hilarious but
one that happened on because Star Wars
was after I was there and stuff but was
the LA shows the Triumph tours the stars
homes right Sweeney Mike you were just
producing that with Robert I believe
there's a moment where your stop at Ted
Danson's house and he and you're like
that's one of my favorite moments ever
that might be the to me the ultimate
Triumph moment because he gets into a
shouting match with these guard dogs and
he's just cursing Dover live the BET The
Genius of Triumph besides all the great
jokes or whatever but he interacts with
real dogs he just gets into it with
these angry guard dogs and he's so mad
and they're so mad it is
what I love about that is the triumph
his pride is being compromised at that
moment
but he has this ego and he's like told
all these people that he's going to get
them into me and his guard dog is giving
him and he gets so emotional like I
was almost crying I was almost crying as
I was yelling at that guard dog yeah
that's how angry I got Ryan Thompson
and um and I was so satisfying to see
the huge lava guy and then and then my
favorite part is that then you cut hard
to just try him going back to the tour
bus who had gotten off the tour bus and
are at dance attention to the all right
back on the bus
those dogs were they would have just
kept going in and going they were
everyone was good listeners they were
good actors so the one thing I remember
from that remote was we went up into
um no no we went up to uh that was a
technical nightmare it was a technical
Nightmare and then very stressful we
drove up into Bel Air and without
permission and on in a double decker bus
which are banned from like we had no
double decker bus had been there in
years they banned them so the branches
were low oh so we had to put someone in
the front of the top of the bus to go
and
all right we headed up to Barbra
Streisand's house and then I remember
you had the bullhorn and you're like hey
Barbara come on out we love all your
crap oh yeah we're big fans
of all your crap what I always remember
is all her neighbors
came flying out like Angry wasps like
weird and she was the queen bee and we
had penetrated her nest and so people
not from her compound came out and
started screaming at us and called the
cops and we got a police escort out of
there when went to that in room we were
like oh my God this is all fantastic
what a day what a day what a great day
look at the footage and it's weirdly the
camera issues and microphone issues
yeah so we're like we weren't sure
whether it was usable so we ended up the
next day
but the crazy thing it was that classic
thing of whenever you try to repeat
something that was a lot where there's a
lot of improvisation the the new
versions didn't have the it just wasn't
as good as the first day so we had to
make that first day work so that whole
second day just like ah oh yeah
everybody checked it out it was just to
make them mad but yeah but the first day
yeah the LAPD wanted to see the cuts
that's right that's right